happy holidays everyone we get this
always an interesting week rodney i'm
gonna start with you and tony what was
christmas week like
in the nfl with meetings and practice
and all that stuff when you're right in
the middle of a playoff race and now
you've got everybody in the house doing
all the stuff that's going on outside
the doors for all of us
mike i was one of those guys that i
didn't i didn't want to be bothered with
a bunch of family and things like that
if i had to prepare for a game i wanted
to just to be my wife maybe my kids and
not a whole bunch of like my mom and my
sister my brother anything like that so
i wanted to keep all the distractions
and all the people at a minimum coach
well as a coach it's different because
you're trying to figure out how to
manage this what do we do on christmas
eve how do we get guys home quick enough
what do we do on christmas day do we
move practice back uh do we start it
early so they can spend the rest of the
day with them and as players you know a
lot of guys don't have kids but uh as
coaches almost everybody does you think
about the staff all of that and still
trying to win a game so it can create
some headaches for sure
and we do have a game on christmas mike
florio with the the vikings in action
and a significant game obviously for new
orleans you know from a fan perspective
and having worked a few christmas day or
night games
they're difficult they're odd but from a
fans perspective it's great to be able
to sit home in the afternoon after gifts
are open the families gathered and watch
an nfl game and we get one with meaning
here on friday
yeah and it's a thanksgiving vibe
definitely
when you have that game on especially
late afternoon in the cowboys
traditional window and for the vikings
they're not officially done yet and even
if they are this is kind of like their
last chance to show people what they can
do like what the bengals did on monday
night against the steelers it's kind of
like a bowl game it's an opportunity to
get everyone's attention and maybe lay
the foundation for next year because
obviously there's no way they're getting
to the playoffs this year but they can
at least go out with some pride intact
if they could upset the saints
you brought it up so i won't let the
cincinnati fans uh do any more
celebrating you all can have your moment
for the rest of the week but tony i'll
start with you on pittsburgh this has
been three four odd weeks here for the
steelers what's the level of concern and
where is the concern for you and rodney
as you watch the steelers lose to
cincinnati monday night
well my concern started about six weeks
ago as they were winning these close
games but really
kind of losing their identity and having
played in pittsburgh and coached in
pittsburgh you come into december
thinking hey we're physical we're tough
we run the football we stop other people
from running that's the way you win
football games in pittsburgh in december
and that hasn't been the case for about
a month now and people are catching up
to that so i think it can be fixed but
i'm not sure if it can be fixed in this
day and age with the rules uh what we
did and what we used to do and i know
what coach noel would do we put the pads
back on and we do some hitting and
practice blocking and tackling and
that's what they need to do but i don't
know if you can
just the way the rules are set up now
and to me i think the most important
thing they have to do is just stick
together as a team you're going to have
the media you're going to have the fans
and everybody has an opinion of what you
should do run the football more this
than the other just stick together and
if you're mike tomlin go to your veteran
players and tell them to spend more time
with some of the young players getting
them a little bit more familiar with the
game plan so it's just about guys
putting more effort in and not putting
you know blaming each other for all the
mistakes and things like that just
sticking together as a team like
yeah how much you like mike
good mike good i'm sorry sorry i i what
i was going to say is almost feel like
they have to bottom out before they can
start digging out of this hole and maybe
the bottom was struck on monday night
against the cincinnati bengals it kind
of reminds me it's a loose corollary to
2005. they lost in cincinnati or either
cincinnati came there and beat them
either way they lost to the bengals and
everyone's like up up up the bengals are
the new
masters of the afc north and that next
week the steelers had a game in
pittsburgh against the bears and it was
a hard fought tough snow in the air type
of a game and that was the spark for
what ultimately became the steelers
getting in by the skin of their teeth
and winning the super bowl that year but
i feel like they need to hit bottom and
maybe they finally have and now the
question is can they start digging out
with the colts and the browns as the two
games that that they have as an
opportunity it's almost like a preseason
to the postseason these are two games
they can prove to themselves they're
ready to win in the playoffs
because they're in and i wanted to get
back to tony's point there about putting
the pads on mike tomlin played that card
already before the buffalo game may have
to play it again but if they don't beat
indianapolis tony and cleveland beats
the jets we can't assume anything as we
learned this week but then cleveland's
got a chance to win the division on week
17. so pittsburgh really has to be
feeling the pressure can they become the
steelers that we know and establish a
running game at this late point in the
season
it can happen i believe that uh it
reminds me a lot of our season in 2006
our super bowl season we started out the
same way in indianapolis 9-0 we're
winning a lot of close games really
weren't playing our style but winning
and then we hit a stretch where we
played badly and we had a game about
this time of year in jacksonville we
lost 44 to 17 and gave up almost 400
yards rushing and everyone said the
season was over i remember talking to
guys and saying we're not getting any
new players we have no hero that's going
to come in and save us we're going to
cut down on what we do we're going to
get back to basics tackle block and and
move the ball that way and
six weeks later we were in the super
bowl uh we we got some guys healthy and
got back but as rodney said it's the
mentality that you have going back and
believing in each other believing in the
system and doing what what you can do
and we keep we keep talking about the
stillers of old and i hear everybody say
to old steelers this is a completely
different team you look at their
offensive line these guys are pla pass
blockers they don't they don't do well
when it comes to grinding putting that
hand in the dirt and knocking people off
the ball so we can't expect them to come
out and try all of a sudden try to run
the ball 30 times a game but i think
what they have to do at least try give
an effort like they did last night try
to run the football use the play action
pass maybe like you talked about with
chicago coach maybe get big ben under
center a little bit more so they can
hand the ball off and use some of those
play actions and things like that but
this the personality of this team is not
of offense it's not a physical pound put
your hand in the dirt and just and just
physically dominate people that's not
their personality
mike so mike florio who's the second
best team in the afc if we all agree
kansas city is number one
is it buffalo at this moment
i think without question it's buffalo i
think something happened to buffalo with
the hail murray play i think losing that
game helped them more than winning it
helped the cardinals the cardinals lost
three in a row after that
the bills i think got upset they had the
game won they let it get away from them
they went to their bye week and i've
heard time and again this year the bye
week how important it is for teams that
didn't have a preseason it didn't have
an off season it's an opportunity to
retool and refocus and they have
undefeated since there by weekend
they've had three straight nationally
televised games two in prime time and
they've risen to the moment and they
keep getting better this is december and
the bills are getting better every week
they blew out the broncos that the
patriots coming up on a monday night
they're going to be ready for the
playoffs and they know very well the
last two times they're in 2017 and last
year they lose in the wild card round
this is a team that strikes me as an
organization that is ready to get to
january and win and i think they are in
the afc the best threat to the chiefs
right now
and i i could agree with you on that
bike but i'll say one thing
the
uh buffalo bills their achilles heel is
their run defense
if they get in and have to play against
baltimore and baltimore is playing the
way they've played the last couple weeks
and they get back to the pound in the
football the other thing baltimore can
do is put pressure on the pastor that is
a matchup that would be very interesting
i do think buffalo has the best chance
to beat kansas city because they can
score points but i i would be very wary
if i was a bills fan and those uh
baltimore ravens rolled into buffalo
yeah i didn't get a chance to really
hear what mike flore is saying i'm
having audio problems but i think
buffalo is definitely that team um i
think you know every single week i look
and i watch their defense they're
playing a lot more aggressive coaching
we talked about this a couple weeks ago
how leslie frazier he's calling a lot
more aggressive game plan and it seems
like those players are really feeding
off of it you see they're creating
turnovers the secondary in particular at
the cornerback position they're playing
outstanding i think they're safe these
are some of the top trio dual safeties
in the league so i like what they're
doing defensively and we know that josh
allen and that offense can put up some
points so i think it's buffalo right now
yeah roger they're going back to pieces
on defense and they felt a much more
comfortable tony as they've gotten to
the second half of the season leslie
frazier getting the pieces that they had
changed a little bit they brought in
some guys with some experience with
carolina going back to sean mcdermott's
system it feels like they all fit
together a heck of a lot better right
now
they are but we have to remember this
going into kansas city you can't go in
there with defense and expect to win
the saints played them about as well as
you can play them they roughed up
mahomes they threw the timing off they
covered
uh they played physical and they gave up
32 points so you played perfect you
still are going to have to score 35 to
40 to beat them buffalo can score that's
why i think they have the best chance to
beat the chiefs
i'm going to flip back over to the nfc
here for a second tony you mentioned new
orleans can you follow up on that
the drew brees situation look early on
he didn't look as comfortable as sharp
as we're used to
what'd you see as the game went on and
what do you think we're going to see
with new orleans these last two weeks
well drew got better and they're going
to need him to get better and i think
sean payton realized that he took a
calculated risk and said i'm gonna go
with my ace
i know from practice he's not a hundred
percent but if we're gonna win in the
playoffs if we're gonna win a super bowl
we need drew in there he wants to play
so i've got to play him uh it may have
cost them a little bit in this game last
week but in the long run i think it'll
it'll help them they're they're a good
defensive team they've got a lot of
weaponry they're going to rest michael
thomas up and try to get him healthy for
the playoffs but the key is drew he's
got to come back he's got to feel
comfortable get that timing back and be
the drew brees that we know in the
playoffs
yeah but drew also has to be honest and
he owes it's his responsibility to his
um coaching staff as well as his um
teammates to be honest about how he's
feeling i don't want a drew brees at 80
percent and 100 taysom hill because i
believe 100 taysom hill is a lot better
than an 80 drew brees at this point in
time in his career so it's his
responsibility to make sure that he
communicates even next week if he starts
and he gets injured he needs to go to
the coaching staff be honest and don't
try to be a hero take himself out of the
game and allow taysom hill to take over
if he's not you know close to 100
percent
mike
yeah look i agree completely and i'd
love to know the story behind the story
as to why you go with drew brees when
he's clearly diminished when you have
taysom hill it makes me wonder desean
payton have doubts about taysom hill
even though for the most part he got a
passing grade during his four starts in
drew brees absence for as much as i've
praised sean payton for being a genius
when it comes to manipulating the media
and keeping his starting quarterback's
identity close to the vest i think he
misfired here it should not have been
drew brees against the chiefs they could
have potentially beaten the chiefs with
taysom hill i'd love to know surely
there's an alternate universe somewhere
where all other facts are the same
except this one taysom hill played
instead of dubrise on sunday i'd love to
know what happened in that game
florio world we should all visit florio
world on a daily basis just for our
imagination new orleans does win the
division if they get the win over over
uh minnesota on christmas day they do
play caroline at week 17 i'm just going
to tell you guys do not sleep on
carolina they continue to play close
games they stayed in it and who knows if
we see christian mccaffrey before the
end guys let me ask you one last
question here and then i'll get to our
sunday night game
tony the rams
i i know the jets in the first round
picking trevor lawrence and all that
stuff we got that that was stunning with
the rams the way they were playing and
now they play seattle in one of those
almost gotta have it games
the biggest game of the sunday afternoon
window late what are your thoughts on
what happened to the rams and what this
week is going to look like for them
two weeks ago i was ready to declare the
rams the most complete team in football
they had everything rolling defensively
they're playing great they're rushing
the passer they have a physical
secondary they're running the football
jared goff is getting all these easy
throws off the play action and the
bootleg they're they're moving it well
and i said this this is the most
complete team but you see what happens
when they aren't able to get that run
game going early the jets came out and
their defensive front stuffed them up
front and once that run game didn't
happen they were a completely different
team so
that that has to put a lot of doubt in
their mind if we play someone in the
playoffs that can stop our run then
where do we go and uh there's to me
there's just some doubt about that
offense right now
yeah and the thing that really stood out
to me was just a lack of passion and
emotion they didn't play with that
energy and it almost seemed like they
were looking forward to this week's game
as opposed to and looking past the jets
when you have a team like that you're
going into playoffs you got to treat
every
opportunity that you have to play
against a team as an opportunity to get
better as a team to win and to continue
that progression right into the playoffs
and i just when i watched the film
yesterday again i just didn't see that
passion i didn't see that energy you saw
guys kind of jogging
to make plays and it just wasn't what i
was used to seeing the rams play like
i got a name for it i got a name for it
i don't think i've ever used this before
and i'll probably forget to use it again
but i'm going to call it an eggnog game
it's christmas week the rams across the
board thought hey it's gay it's
christmas week this the jets they stink
look at what happened to him in seattle
they're no good we're good it's on the
players it's on the coaches it's on
everyone they should have sensed and
probably in hindsight sean mcvay is
kicking himself for not sensing that a
malaise kind of settled in that they
thought all they had to do was show up
and uh you know next year week of
christmas i'm going to be watching every
game to see where that eggnog game is
because this was the 2020 eggnog game
do you do you like eggnog mike
no i hate it i've never had it i just i
know there's something about
no i i've never had it never had it i i
just the thought of it any any liquid
with egg in the title is not is not
appealing to me
if i want something that thick
i hate it you hate it tony
i i know that i actually like eggnog and
i know the feeling that mike is talking
about and you do have to guard against
that as a coach but i'm not sure that
was it with the rams uh i i just think
if you can stop the rams from running
the ball and and setting that physical
tempo on offense early they're a
different team
i thought tony was going to say i know
what mike's talking about with eggnog
but he turned it right back to football
thankfully keeping us on the rails here
all right last one rodney i'll give you
the first swing at this tennessee green
bay our sunday night game is a huge game
derek henry who if he can have two big
games can think about 2 000 yards aaron
rodgers 40 touchdowns incredible season
bad second half for their packers
offense in the game against carolina
saturday night at lambeau rodney what
are you looking forward to in this
matchup on sunday night football
tackling are you kidding me who's going
to tackle derrick henry i mean tackling
and even davonte adams because you know
aaron rodgers with all these big wide
receivers he's like to get to get the
ball out quick and force these dbs to
tackle you know some of these big wide
receivers so i'm really excited to see
if green bay will step up their
linebackers their safeties their
cornerbacks and tackle i'm no dumb trunk
[Laughter]
well i'm excited about the game because
to me it's strength against weakness
tennessee can do a lot of things really
well but they don't rush the passer and
they don't have a great secondary that
spells trouble against aaron rodgers
green bay does a lot of things well but
they don't stop the run particularly
inside run they've got past threshers
off the edge but now
can tennessee get their strength derrick
henry going against green bay's weakness
and how does tennessee
put up some type of
fence or roadblock to stop aaron rodgers
i think it could be a high scoring
really entertaining game people are
i didn't know this until i read it
yesterday tennessee has the highest
scoring offense in football so we're
going to see some points on the board
yeah absolutely
and you know the packers have been prone
to starting slowly that's all right the
packers are prone to starting slowly at
home this year they finally had a fast
start on saturday night against the
panthers and then they had to fight to
hold on the titans are a little more
desperate in this one though i think
this time of year when
there are you know you start checking
the boxes and it looks pretty even the
titans don't have a playoff berth nailed
down yet and they could blow it and fall
out of the postseason altogether and i
think they're going to be a little
hungrier for this one and and i i right
now i i feel like this is a bad matchup
for the packers because that the titans
do have that great offense they do have
that hunger they know the stakes and and
we've seen it with the packers they're
prone to having that bad game just kind
of out of nowhere and that could be on
sunday night when it happens
yeah tennessee
indy cleveland baltimore miami one of
those teams will not make the playoffs
so these last two weeks are essential
for those teams and then we're going to
be watching that rams arizona situation
a potential week 17 there and chicago
keeps keeps hanging around here and has
a chance to get to eight and seven if
they can win onset it's fun we've gotten
down the last couple of weeks there's
that extra playoff berth but there's
still good races to be had here in the
nfl guys have a great great great
christmas with your families luckily for
us we get to spend christmas with our
families and then go to work for the
good nfl weekend so uh merry christmas
to you all
yeah thank you and uh all right and i
hope scrooge brings you a piece of coal
and eggnog gloria
i'll eat the coal before i drink the
eggnog thanks mike
merry christmas everybody we'll see you
now football night at seven eastern
tennessee bay
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports